le second procès du Médiator s'est
ouvert en début de semaine devant la
cour d'appel de Paris le Médiator c'est
cet anti diabétique prescrit pendant 33
ans comme coupe-faim à 5 millions de
patients et qui seraient à l'origine de
1500 à 2000 décès pendant presque 10 ans
marilyna salvailor s'est vu prescrire ce
médicament pourtant aujourd'hui elle ne
fait pas partie des elle ne fait pas
partie des parties civils elle a jeté
tous les documents de cette époque
pensant qu'il n'y aurait jamais de
procès et les Turquie s'est rendue chez
elle à beaumont-louesto
c'était il y a 11 ans nous avions
rencontré Marilyn elle venait tout juste
de porter plainte contre les
laboratoires Serviers la raison une
prise quotidienne du Médiator pendant
près de 10 ans prescrit à l'origine
comme coupe-faim une ordonnance lourde
de conséquences et depuis tout ce temps
un combat acharné j'avais porté plainte
il y a une dizaine d'années et après les
serviettes les laboratoires vers des
Serviers on dit que j'avais pu droit à
accès à rien parce que je n'étais pas
suffisamment malade donc on a dit on
arrête sauf que je suis tombé malade
j'ai fait un AVC on m'a amputé d'une
jambe j'ai des problèmes de poumons et
voilà on va m'opérer de l'aorte
une opération du coeur prochainement et
depuis 2015 en fauteuil électrique sa
vie change du tout au tout après la
prise du Médiator déjà ça c'est tous les
jours chaque jour ça sauve que le matin
ça désormais en seconde procès vient de
s'ouvrir un soulagement mais n'ayant
plus de preuves matérielles de la
prescription de ce comprimé elle suit
l'affaire à distance surtout pour
apporter son soutien aux participes moi
je te souhaite qu'elle gagne de façon à
ce que j'ai Verdié le laboratoire ferme
ou alors qui donne une enveloppe énorme
c'est que si on doit avoir quelque chose
qu'au moins qu'on rembourse la sécurité
sociale parce que on dit la sécurité
sociale mais on est très heureux de
l'avoir aujourd'hui Maryline tente de
reconstituer son dossier pour
éventuellement pouvoir faire entendre sa
voix d'ici la fin du procès prévu dans 6
mois